hey little guys my name is a cheddar and
welcome back to my say plus plus series
today I'm going to be talking about
constructive member initializer lists
that's quite a sentence basically what
it means is it so it's a way for us to
initialize our class member functions in
the Constructors so when we write a
class and we add members to that class
we usually want some way of initializing
those members and that's usually done in
the constructor and there are two ways
we can really initialize a class member
in the constructor let's take a look so
I've got this entity class here which
just has a name string it doesn't have
any constructors yes let's add one of
those may be a constructor that actually
takes a name in as a parameter I'll also
create one more constructor that's just
going to be a default constructor and it
won't take any parameters so in this
case I want to assign M name with value
of this name as being passed in because
I want to be able to set my entity to
have the name that was passed in through
this parameter in this case maybe I'll
do something simple and just set the
player's name to unknown now this might
seem fine and it's probably the way that
you've been doing this in all the
languages but in C++ there's actually
one other way we could do this and
that's why I remember initialize a list
first of all let's just take a look at
this card and say it running and make
sure it works so I'm just going to
create a new entity over here and I'm
going to print the name of that entity
I'll pull this one easier to demonstrate
my first kind of case and then another
one with a one I'll give this one a name
such as shadow and we'll hit f5 you can
see in this case we get online printing
first in that show okay great so
everything seems to work let's take a
look at the second way we can initialize
this instead of us just setting M name
equal to the value over here we can do
it via remember initialize the list
which looks like this after B construct
after or after you write your
constructor and the parameters we can
add a colon this can be on the same line
as this it doesn't really matter usually
I like to write it on the next line over
here invented like this and then you
start listing off the members that you
want to initialize now in this case
we've just got M name so all we have to
do is type in the name of this variable
and then give
some kind of values in this case unknown
and that kind of replaces the need to do
this so this is what a member in ich
lies the list is now if we had another
member such as score or something like
that we would just add a comma and then
the value of that man but so in this
case I'm initializing it to zero one
thing to note really quickly is that if
we had defined these variables like this
in this initializer list you should be
listing off all the members in order and
some compilers will actually warn you if
you don't write the code in order and
the reason this is important is because
no matter how you write your initializer
list it will be initialized in the order
of the actual class members I defined
them so in this case the integer will be
initialized first and then the string
even if you write it the other way
around in the initializer list where you
initialize the string first and then the
integer so this can lead to all sorts of
kind of dependency problems if you if
you break that order so just make sure
that you always initialize your
variables in the same order that they
declare in when you declare them as
members in this situation it would look
like this we have our name and then we
just put in the value that we want to
copy from into here like this and that's
how we assign this it's just you're
basically replacing the equals with
parentheses and moving it up into this
list if we run our code you'll see we
get the exact same result okay that's it
that's member initializer lists really
easy the big question though is why why
do why should we use this is it just a
Coast style thing and the answer is well
yes and no norm is probably the more
right answer I like writing code like
this first of all because if you have a
lot of if you have a lot of member
variables this can get really cluttered
if you start analyzing them all in here
and it might be hard to see what the
constructor is actually doing because
maybe you've got some code later on that
does other stuff but most of your
constructor is filled with just
initializing variables such kind of
trivial and boring casts that you
probably don't even want you might want
to hire them which is why I like to put
them in the member initializer list
because just from a code style point of
view I just I do I like it more it keeps
my actual code in my constructor very
very clean and easy to read but there is
actually a functional difference
different supplies to classes
specifically if you write code such as
this where we assign an M name to
something here like unknown and you
don't have it any member initializer
list like so what will actually happen
is this M name object will be
constructed twice once with the default
constructor and then again with this
unknown parameter because what's
happening here is actually this so you
just credit two strings one of them
you've just thrown away pretty much
straight away right it's a waste of
performance right there let's
demonstrate this I'm going to make a
class here called example it's going to
be very very simple just one public
constructor here we'll make this kind of
more of a real-world example I guess
I'll just print created entity over here
and then I'll also create one example
which actually takes in a parameter and
I'll Prince rated entity with and in
that X variable I'm going to scroll down
here get rid of all this X stuff I'm
going to add this example class as an
actual class member over here I'll call
it m on this Court example to adhere to
my convention so this is it that's the
whole class it's got two constructors
one which takes no parameters and one
which takes this s and what I really
want to do is in my default constructor
for entity my constructor which takes no
parameters I just want to set example
equal to an example object that actually
takes in 8 right so if I come down here
and I make sure I'm actually creating
this let's get rid of this other example
we're going to print this and we get rid
of the printing it get name all I'm
doing here is just creating an instance
of that entity object with this default
constructor
if I hit f5 to run my code look at that
we created two entities once with the
default constructor the one that takes
no parameters and once with the
constructor the techs in an integer so
we've actually created two entities
right one was created up here it's as if
we wrote this like this right I mean it
created an entity here why wouldn't it
create an example up here just because
it's in this kind of member region
doesn't mean that it's not going to run
this
and created and then we've also created
a new example instance here and assign
it to the old one so we've thrown away
the old one we've just created an
example class instance throwing that
away and just overwritten it with a new
one we've created two objects instead of
just one right whereas if we were to
move this into the initializer list
there's two options for us here we could
either write exactly the same code as we
did before
like this and if I hit at five you'll
see of course we just we just run the
constructor that we want we create one
st instance or I could even just get rid
of this and just passing the parameters
like this and just hit a file and you
can see that does exactly the same thing
so there you go that's the difference
right you should be using member
initializer lists everywhere right
there's absolutely no reason not to use
them if you don't like the code style
get used to them because it's not just a
matter of style it's actually there's
actually a functional difference you'll
be literally wasting performance if
you're not using them of course not in
all cases in the case of primitive types
like integers you it wouldn't be
initialized them until you initialize
them yourself by assigning it but I use
it everywhere I don't discriminate
between primitive classes in class types
you should just be using initialized
lists like this everywhere but anyway
that's gonna wrap up today's episode of
my C++ series look at me saying today's
episode as if this is daily now I think
this is the third day in a row that's
why I'm doing pretty well if you guys
appreciate that please hit that like
button if you want to support the series
you can go over to patreon the concourse
at rachona I've got some pretty cool
rewards set up I'm actually kind of
trying a bit of a discord server so
patreon rewards include that you can
also join it for free though of course
link in the description below like a
discord thing but on patreon you get
some cool rolls on that server as well
as access to some of these videos early
when they happen to be ready early
because sometimes that just not but for
those times they are available to you as
soon as I basically finish editing them
as well as like a
we've got like a private discord / slack
kind of group in which we can talk about
save us bus stop external just directly
as well as as well as you guys can
suggest new topics and videos for me to
make and that's what I usually do like
this one here so I'll see you guys next
time good bye
[Music]
[Music]